[موسيقى]
عندما تعطس امريكا تصاب اوروبا بنزله برد
وكذلك بقيه العالم فالكل يعيش على ايقاع
الاقتصاد والدولار الامريكيين ولذلك سرعان
ما انتقلت عدوى افلاسه ثلاثه بنوك امريكيه
قبل نحو اسبوعين الى اوروبا المفاجاه هذه
المره انها اصابت ثانيه اكبر بنك سويسري
كريدي سويس وهو ايضا احد 30 بنكا كانت
تصنف على مستوى العالم بانها اكبر من ان
تفشل ورغم تدخل البنوك المركزيه للحد من
النزيف وتجنب الاسوا الا ان الاضطراب
المالي لم ينتهي بعد وهما اكدته رئيسه
البنك المركزي الاوروبي كريستي بقولها ان
التوترات الاخيره التي تحيط بالقطاع
المصرفي تطرح مخاطر جديده تهدد الاقتصاد
الاوروبي فهل نحن امام ازمه مصرفيه في
حاله انحسار ام في حاله انتشار وما هي
تداعيات التي يواجه الاقتصاد العالمي وما
حجمه تاثيرها على منطقتنا العربيه اهلا
بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم رمضان كريم وكل عام وانتم
بخير من كاليفورنيا الى سوريا وبسرعه
فائقه ترددت اصداء ازمه المصرفيه حاده على
مدى الايام الماضيه بعد ان اتسع نطاق
الصدوع في القطاع المصرفي على ضفتي
الاطلسي عن ابعاد هذه الازمه والمخاوف من
تاثير التي يمكن ان يؤدي الى ازمه
المصرفيه اكبر يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه
الحلقه من الاستوديو الدكتور جلال القناص
الاستاذ المساعد في الاقتصاد في جامعه قطر
والمتخصص في اقتصاديات النقد والبنوك من
زوريخ ستيفان جيرلاخ كبير الاقتصاديين في
المجموعه الماليه الدوليه اي اف جي بنك
ومن مدينه ساوث فيلد في ولايه ميشيغان
الامريكيه الدكتور مصطفى شاهين استاذ
الاقتصاد في كليه اوكلاند الامريكيه فاهلا
بهم جميعا
الازمه المصرفيه الحاليه التي ظهرت فجاه
في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه اثارت
الكثيره من الذعر واعادت الى الذاكره
احداث الازمه الماليه عام 2008 التي امتدت
اثارها من الولايات المتحده الى اوروبا
الى اسيا وكشفت هشاشه النظام الماليه فهل
تتدحرج الازمه الحاليه نحو الاسوا وتتسع
رقعتها كما حدث في الازمه السابقه نتعرف
في البدايه في هذا التسلسل الزمني على قصه
الافلاس المفاجئ لبنك سيليكون فاني وما
تلاه من انهيارات اخرى
[موسيقى]
بدا كل شيء حينما اشهر هذا البنك في ولايه
كاليفورنيا الامريكيه افلاسه كان
السيليكون فالي يعرف نفسه بانه الشريك
المالي للاقتصادات المبتكره فهو مختص في
تمويل الشركات الناشئه خصوصا العامله في
قطاع التكنولوجيا فاذا اسست شركه ناشئه في
الولايات المتحده فستلجا على الاغلب لهذا
البنك لتحصل على تمويل او لتودع فيه
التمويل الذي حصلت عليه كان ذلك بفضل
معدلات الفائده التي كانت منخفضه قبل
العام الماضي ما حدث لاحقا هو ان البنك
الفيدرالي الامريكي رفع اسعار الفائده
قرابه ثمانيه اضعاف منذ مارس 2022 لكبح
جماح التضخم اصبح البنك مضطرا لدفع مبالغ
اكبر للمذيعين تقابلها عوائد منخفضه من
استثماراته
ما ان لاحت بوادر الازمه حتى هرع المذيعون
لسحب ودائعهم في يوم واحد من بنك
السيليكون فالي حدث الانهيار ولم يكن ذلك
سوى بدايه لها ما بعدها فقد اشهر بعد ذلك
بنكاء سيجنتشر وسيلفر جيت افلاسهما وهما
مرتبطان ايضا بشركات التكنولوجيا
المستثمره في العملات الرقميه والمشفره من
سويسرا جاءت بوادر هيار بنك بعد ذلك لتعزز
مخاوف المستثمرين الهشه اصلا من ان النظام
المصرفي ربما يواجه ازمه جديده
وحتى باستحواذ مصرف على منافسه كريدي سويس
لم تتبدد المخاوف من ازمه عالميه في
المنطقه العربيه ايضا يخشى من تداعيات
لذلك لا سيما في المنطقه الخليجيه التي
لها استثمارات عالميه مباشره وغير مباشره
فالمستثمرون الخليجيون يمتلكون نحو خمس
بنكد الاولى بالبنك الاهلي السعودي اكبر
مساهم في البنك السويسري وجهاز قطر
للاستثمار ثاني اكبر مساهم في البنك ذاته
يحاول قطاع المال في المنطقه طمانه
المستثمرين بان لا تاثيرات مباشره لانهيار
البنوك الامريكيه والبنك السويسري على
القطاع المصرفي او على الاستثمارات
الخليجيه اجمالا لكن حاله عدم اليقين
الناجمه عن الاضطرابات الاخيره ستقود حتما
الى اعاده تقييم المخاطر واعاده توزيع
المحافظ الاستثماريه بناء على ذلك دكتور
جلال القناص اهلا وسهلا بك
هذه الازمه التي تابعنا بعض فصولها هل
ستتواصل اولا شكرا جزيلا على هذه الدعوه
الكريمه واسمي وباسم كليه الاقتصاد بجامعه
قطر بتمنى لكل المشاهدين ولكم رمضان كريم
اهلا وسهلا رمضان كريم شكرا جزيلا
الموضوع طبعا هذا الموضوع هلا اول موضوع
اللي
بعتقد شغل بال اكثر العالم بالاسواق
وبالجامعات
وبالاسواق الماليه بالذات
هون فينا لازم نطلع على ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه
اول شيء شو هي مسبباتها لهاي الازمه يعني
ماذا حصل قبل ان ان يسقط السيليكون بالي
وبعدين بنشوف شو هي تاثيراتها على على على
الاسواق فاول شيء السيليكون فالي هو كنقطه
اولى هو بنك متخصص في شركات الناشئه تم
انشاءه 1985 تقريبا
وكان الفكره الاساسيه وتقديم قروض
وتسهيلات لهاي الشركات الناشئه اللي هي
متخصصه بقطاعه التكنولوجيا او قطاعات اللي
نوعا ما هي تعتبر لها مخاطره عاليه فهو
بنك متخصص بالاصل يعني كميزانيه
بقروض وتسهيلات لمجالات مخاطره العاليه
فهذا احد اهم الاسباب ثاني سبب هو موضوع
الرقابه الماليه هذا البنك ما كان تحت
الرقابه الماليه الشديده مثل البنوك
الكبيره السبب ليش من 2008 2009 كان في
رقابه ماليه شديده لاكثر البنوك بسبب
الازمه اللي صارت ولكن لما اجت ترامب على
الحكم
قرر يخفض يرفع سقف الاصول اللي البنوك
اللي تحت الرقابه الماليه الشديده لحد 250
بليون دولار هو كان هذا البنك خمسين
باليوم بس من 2018 ل 2022 ارتفعت اصوله
بكمان جذب الودائع من الخمسين بليون
تقريبا لل 212 بليون خلال اربع سنين فهي
في نظره هون لازم يكون ماذا حدث وين
الرقابه الماليه اللي عم بتصير وتعالت
نقطه اللي هي برايي الاهم طبعا هو معالجه
البنوك المركزيه بالذات
البنك المركزي الامريكي الفيدرالي برفع
اسعار الفائده بسبب ارتفاع التضخم طبعا
هون كمان السؤال هل هذه هي السياسه
التي يجب اتباعها لمحاربه التضخم عن تضخم
له اسباب ممكن نحكي فيها بالتفاصيل فرفع
اسعار الفائده اثرت بكتير على عمل البنوك
اسرت كتير على عمل حتى الاقتصاديات بشكل
عام وهذا له دور كبير بالشيء اللي صار مع
السيليكون عندما نعرف هذه البدايه دكتور
مصطفى شاهين دائما البدايات تكون من
امريكا
والمساله مرتبطه
بزياده الفائده هي التي ربما ادت على
الاقل في هذا ما يقال الان عندما نعرف
الاسباب وعرفنا الاسباب ونرى ما حدث هل
تتوقع ان تستمر الامور على هذا النحو
اولا دعني ارحب بحضرتك استاذ محمد وبكل
ضيوف حضرتك الكرام وكل الساده المشاهدين
في العالم العربي ورمضان كريم وكل عام
وحضراتكم بخير رمضان كريم
ردا لسؤال على حضرتك
هذه الموجه الحياه درس قوي جدا وبليغ
للاداره الماليه داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فخرج علينا بالامس محافظ البنك
الفيدرالي الامريكي واعلن ان هنالك
اجراءات مشدده
ستطالبنوك خاصه في عمليه الاقراض او
الاقتراض او الرقابه المصرفيه على اداء كل
البنوك داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هو اعلن ذلك بالامس ليس هذا فحسب بل ان هو
رفع سعر الفائده بالامس ربع % حتى يستطيع
ان هو يحد من التضخم لكن وزاره الماليه
الامريكيه السيده وزيره الماليه الامريكيه
جاني قالت صراحه
انا لن نتوقف عن مساعده اي بنك بل ان
الرئيس الامريكي نفسه الرئيس بايدن اعطى
لكل المدعين داخل البنوك الامريكيه القدره
على استعاده كل اموالهم لان كنا هنبقى في
كارثه شديده جدا لو ان كل المواطنين
الامريكيين ذهب وسحبوا كل الودائع التي
اودعوها في البنوك فهذا حتما سيؤدي الى
كارثه ماليه محققه كما حدث في كارثه 1929
وعلشان كده الرئيس الامريكي حتى الحد او
القيد اللي كان محطوط ان لكل مدع انه يسحب
250 الف دولار الان بلا قيد وبلا اي حد اي
مواطن امريكي مودع امواله في اي بنك من
البنوك يستطيع ان هو يسحب امواله كامله
وعلشان كده البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي
بالتعاون مع البنوك المركزيه الاوروبيه
بيضمن ودائع المواطنين في كافه الدول
وبدون اي حد اقصى فهذا ان الناس بالامس
وجدنا ان اسعار الاسهم ارتفعت نعم صحيح
هناك انخفاض في اسعار بعض اسهم البنوك
الضعيفه او الصغيره لكن بدون ادنى شك
الموجه في طريقها الى الانحصار ولكن مع
تجديد من الاجراءات الرقابيه من السلطات
النقديه في كل من اوروبا وامريكا على
اعمال البنوك لان لا يمكن ان يسمح ابدا ان
يكون الاستثمار في القروض اعطاءا واقتراضا
خاصه في سندات الامريكيه هذا الامر لن
يستمر كثيرا وستكون عليه قيود شديده يعني
اذا قلنا بان هذه الازمه لن تستمر سيد
ستيفان جيرلاخ من من زريخ هل ايضا لن
تستمر حتى في اوروبا لان اللافت انها
بسرعه انتقلت من الولايات المتحده الى
اوروبا مع كريدي سويس والازمه المعروفه
هذا هو السؤال الرئيسي الذي ليس لدي اي
طرف جواب عليه او جواب جيد المشكله في
الاستقرار المالي او عدم الاستقرار المالي
هي ان الامور تبدو نموذجيه وجيده لكن فجاه
لجنه مؤسسه او مصرفا
يقع في ضائقه وبالتالي لم يكن هناك اي خطر
في اي خلل في استقرار المالي قبل اسابيع
ولك فجاه نجد الى هذه
المصرف يفلس في الولايات المتحده سويس
ايضا وبالتالي من الصعب جدا بالنسبه
للمصارف المركزيه والسلطات التنظيميه ان
يحادوا شيئا انا ارى ان الوضع يبدو جيدا
ولكن مره اخرى اقول قد يحصل اي شيء
في القوه الدافعه هنا هي الزياده
المركزيه معدلات اسعار الفائده اسرع بكثير
ما كانت تتوقع المسار في الاخرى والمسار
في المركزيه ما زالت تستمر في زياده اسعار
الفائده ولكن سيد قال لك عندما تسارع
البنوك المركزيه لمد هذه البنوك المتعثره
او المفلسه بسيوله
وتذهب اخرى الى الاندماج مثل يو بي اس
وكريدي سويس هل هذه حلول معقوله للمستقبل
اعتقد
الولايات المتحده واضحه جدا فهناك مصرفان
سيطرته
اما في حاله
فعلينا ان ننتظر كيف سيجري الامر لانه
الخطا او المخاطر الحاليه على الاستقرار
المالي قد جرت التخلص منها ولكن الان
لدينا خطر اخر كبير جدا
احد المصارف الكبيره جدا الذي ميزانيته
ضعف زانيه
وبالتالي فهذا الوضع صعب جدا كيف يمكن
لمصرفه بهذا الحجم الكبير ان يصادف مشاكل
علينا انتظر لو هل ان يو اس بي تقلص هذا
المصرف
هلباعه او اي شيء اخر علينا ان ننتظر لنرى
في الانتظار دكتور قناص يعني فعلا يعني
مثلا
هو بنك انشئ عام 1856 وكان يعتبر من من
اعرق البنوك واكثرها قوه هذه الموجه الكل
يؤكد الان على الاقل انها على الاغلب في
انحسار ولكن اهتزاز الثقه بالبنوك خاصه في
بلد مثل سويسرا مات داعياته بالنسبه
للفتره المقبله هلا انا برايي الشخصي يعني
تعقيبا طبعا للسؤال للضيوف انا برايي سوف
تستمر يعني لانه المسببات ما زالت موجوده
من 2008 2009 لحد اليوم ما زالت البنوك
تاخذ المخاطر التي ليست فعلا تحت الرقابه
الماليه القويه
البنوك اذا بتلاحظ عم تكبر اكثر وفي بنوك
عم بتروح مع الوقت مثل السيليكون فالي تم
شرائه باليوكاي مثلا الف
بسويسرا عن طريق اليو بي اس
فانا برايي طول ما المسببات موجوده
بالذات موضوع الرقابه الماليه وموضوع
الرفع سعر الفائده اللي هو له دور كبير
بوضع هاي الميزانيات وهاي البنوك بهذا
الخطر ولكن الموضوع الرقابه موضوع مهم لان
بانه التصقت به بعض الفضائح وهناك اشكالات
في التسيير الاداري حتى البنك اعترف بها
يعني موضوع الرقابه كيف يمكن ان
يشتد عوده في المستقبل لمنع مثل هذه
الاحداث مره اخرى طبعا يعني هاي النقطه
جدا مهمه يعني طرحت اهم نقطه برايي بكل
المشكله الكبيره
براي الرقابه الماليه عندما يبدا البنك
المركزي او البنوك المركزيه البنك المركزي
الامريكي هو البنك المركزي العالمي يعني
هو اللي بقرر سياسات الامور النقديه بكل
العالم بتاثر على اوروبا وبياثر على على
دول المنطقه
فاذا استمر بالسياسه مجرد
ما يسمى استهداف التضخم وما بيركز على
موضوع استقرار المالي وما بركز على موضوع
انه شو عم بصير بهاي البنوك يعني موضوع
شغله جديده بدات اكثر من سنتين او ثلاثه
حتى موضوع السيليكون فالي يعني اخر سنتين
بالرقابه الماليه في نيويورك تايمز نزلت
مقال عم تحكي انه انه كان في علاقه بين
السي اي او يعني مدير التنفيذي لانه هو
جزء من
الداركتورز المدراء بالبنك المركزي بسام
فرنسيسكو فكانوا عم يحكوا في مشاكل وعم
بحكوا في قصص طيب ليش ما تدخلوا ليش ما
قالوا بس في سياسات بالبنك المركزي انه
التضخم هو اهم من معالجه الاستقرار المالي
براي البنك المركزي اذا لم يدع
السياسه الاولى الاولى لاله هو الاستقرار
المالي
وبعيد لانه برجع بقول التضخم له اسبابه
التضخم الحالي ما له اي سبب بموضوع زياده
الطلب مثل ما البنوك المركزيه موضوع متعلق
بزياده تكاليف متعلق بزياده الارباح البنك
المركزي لا يستطيع ان يتعامل مع هذا
الموضوع لازم يترك للسياسه الماليه
السياسه النقديه قادره على الاستقرار
المالي فيجب التركيز على الاستقرار يعني
ما اثرته من تساؤلات هامه حول البنك
المركزي الامريكي نسال عنه الدكتور مصطفى
شاهين ما الدور الذي يمكن ان يقوم به
المركز الامريكي
بمثل هذه الاهميه في الولايات المتحده
والعالم لجعل هذا لجعل ما حدث يتوقف او
على الاقل تكون اضراره محدوده
هو الحقيقه اللي احنا فيه الان هو امتداد
لما حدث في 2008
و208 كان هناك تسهيلات شديده جدا في قضيه
الاجراد اللي هو ما يعرف بالمرجج باكس
قضيه القروض التي تم منحها للمواطنين ورغم
ان كانت جدرتهم الائتمانيه سيئه جدا
للغايه هو اللي اوقعنا في ازمه 2008 ما
حدث اخيرا في بنك سيليكون فالي هو بالمقام
الاول لان الرئيس ترامب حينما قام بدا ما
يعرف بدا يتخذ ما يعرف بالدير بدا يعمل
تسهيلات اخرى مره اخرى للبنوك خارج الاطار
التنظيمي وده طلع بالقانون فالان السنه او
الكونجرس الامريكي بدا الان يعيد مره اخرى
اجراءات مشدده على البنوك حتى لا تستمر
هذه العدوى فهناك اجراءات ستكون شديده جدا
على استثمارهم او اقتراضهم او اقتراضهم
لان الشديد اغلب الاستثمارات كانت لبنك
سيليكون فالي كانت في شراء نفس السندات
سيئه السمعه سندات شراء البيوت وديت هي
التي ادى لما ارتفع سعر الفائده في البنك
الفيدرالي ادى الى انخفاض قيمتها فخسر
البنك سلكون فاليك جزء كبير جدا من قيمته
ولم يستطع رد الودائع للمذيعين وعشان كده
البنك الفيدرالي اتدخل فاحنا المره دي
الحقيقه الازمه جايه في شق واحد شق
التعامل بالفوائد اقراضا واقتراضا ولا
يوجد اي استثمارات للبنوك الحقيقه هذه
ماساه كبيره جدا لكن هذا هو نمط البنوك
التجاريه في العالم كله ان هذه البنوك لا
تقوم باي استثمارات في مشروعات حقيقيه
ولكن تقوم باقراض وهناك فرق شاشه بين قضيه
الاقراض وقضيه الاستثمار لكن هذا ليس محل
الان اللي محله الان ان البنك الفيدرالي
شاف الثغره اللي جات له في قضيه المرقش
باك سكيورتيز اللي هي السندات الره
العقاريه هيبدا يحد من البنوك في الاقراض
فيها
والكونجرس الان بدا الحزب الديمقراطي
بيطالب البنوك بانها تقوم بحد كثير جدا من
المصاريف التي تقوم بتغريمها للمواطنين
الامريكان بحكم ان انا كفدره بنك بنك
فدرالي امريكي انا اللي حميت البنوك وانا
اللي وقفتها على رجليها هذه الوقفه لا
ينبغي ابدا انها تمر مرور القرام خاصه زي
ضيف حضرتك تحدث من ان هناك فساد داخل
البنوك في قضيات في قضايا الاقراض
والاقتراض وطبعا هنالك صعوبه شديده جدا
الحقيقه على ان احنا نقدر نحاصر هذا الامر
يعني الامر الحقيقه من اول جرين بان هو
اللي عمل التسهيلات هو اللي فتح الافق
للاقراض والاقتراض السيء وهو ده اللي
اوقعنا في 2008 لكن البنك الفيدرالي اخذ
احتياطيات كثيره وانا ظني ان هو سيكون
هناك اجراءات مشدده شديده جدا على قضيه
الفوائد البنكيه والاقراض وكافه التعاملات
البنكيه حتى يضمن الحفاظ على النظام
المالي استقرار النظام المالي لان هو ده
شريان الاقتصاد وهو ده اللي بيؤدي لنمو في
الاقتصاد يعني مثلا هذا بالنسبه للبنك
المركزي الامريكي بالنسبه للبنك المركزي
سيد جلاخ مثلا
تدخل بقوه
وسارع في عمليه الادماج بين يو بي اس
وكريدي سويس البنك المركزي السويسري او
بقيه البنوك المركزيه الاوروبيه هل لها
دور الان في المرحله المقبله حتى تجعل
ظاهره
تتوقف عند هذا الحد الذي شهدناه الى الان
ان تدخل السلطات السويسريه والمصرف الوطني
السويسري نجحوا كانهم اطفاء حريق
هدؤوا الازمه الوقت الحالي ولا اعتقد ان
ستواصل بنفسها لوحدها وبالتالي يعطن الوضع
اصبح مستقرا لكن لكن قلق الذي اشهده انا
هنا لو ان مؤسسه ماليه اخرى في احدى الدول
الاوروبيه
تاثرت بهذه الزياده الكبيره في اسعار
الفائده انذاك المشكله قد تتكرر وتعود لكن
حاليا لا ارى امكانيه لهذا الوضع ولكن من
الصعب جدا ان نتاكد والامور قد تبدو
مختلفه تماما غدا او الاسبوع القادم او
الشهر القادم وبالتالي علينا نامل ما هو
افضل على امل بانتظاره كيف تتطور الامور
سيد قال لك منذ البدايه نتحدث عن الازمه
وكانها في عالم البنوك والمال والاعمال
فقط
التداعيات الا قتصاديه المتوقعه على
اقتصادات اوروبا واقتصادات العالم كيف
تراها
اعتقد ان القلق الرئيسي هنا هو نظرا ان
هناك مخاوف شديده من حول المصارف والمدعون
ايضا يشعرون بقلق زعل صارف فانهم يحاولون
الان اي هذه الملوك تحاول ان تبين نفسها
انها شديده وقويه امام مدعيها لتجنب وضع
سحب كبير كميات كبيره للاذاعات كيف يحققون
ذلك على ارجاع اعتقد نفس يبداون بتقييد
كميات الاقراض التي يقدمونها خاصه بالنسبه
للمقترضين الذين ليس لديهم مصداقيه كبيره
كما انهم قد يزيدوا فوائد
المفروضه على القروض التي يمنحونها
بالنسبه لاقتصاد ككل الامر سيبدو وكانه
تعزيز
لشروط الاقتراض سيكلف الامر كلفه اعلى
الحصول على تمويل بل وسيكون صعبا للحصول
على المزيد من التمويل مقارنه المكان
تقطيع المنازل ان تحصلها قبل شهر او سنه
التجديد على الشروط منحى القروض وهذا
بدوره سيقلل وسرعه عجله الاقتصاد الشركات
والاشخاص ان يقترضوا بالكميات السابقه
وبالسهوله السابقه والقلق الذي يظهر حاليا
هل ان هذا يمكن
ان يدفع بالاقتصاد العالمي الى حاله ركود
اقتصادي او كساد طبعا
الفيدرالي المركزي الامريكي زاد
من اكثر من 25% لقناه الاشهر الماضيه وهذا
زاد من مخاطر الركود الاقتصادي والان هذا
تقييد التجديد على القروض
ستفرضه تفرضها البنوك سيكون دفعه اضافيه
للاقتصاد نحو رده التوجه نحو كساد او
الركود هروب المذيعين
مهم جدا يعني مثلا بالنسبه لسيليكون فالي
المذيعين عفوا بالنسبه لسيليكون فالي في
يوم واحد تم سحب 40 مليار دولار يعني رقم
مهول لكن يبدو ان الامور هدات قليلا بعد
ان تم ضمان كل المبالغ المودعه خاصه بعد
قررت البنك المركزي وكلام الرئيس بايدن
الان هل يخشى ان الهلع قد يستمر بفتره
وربما هذه لا تطمان الكثيرين في اوروبا او
في مناطق اخرى هل تتوقع ان يستمر هذا
الخوف
طبعا مثل ما تحدثنا سابقا برايي انه ممكن
يستمر لانه المسببات لم تتغير يعني هذا
الموضوع جدا مهم هلا بالنسبه للمذيعين
بالنسبه للسيليكون فالي لهم طبيعه خاصه
برجع بقولن مودعين لشركات ناشئه اصحاب راس
مال بيسميه راس المال مغامر يبحثون عن
الارباح يبحثون عن الاماكن الافضل للربح
واكثر الايداعات اللي كانت موجوده
بالسيليكون فاليت تسمى ادعات تحت الطلب هي
اذاعات يتم سحبها باي وقت هلا في بعض
البنوك الكبيره في بايداعات تسمى ادعات
اجل مسمى وايداعات تحت الطلب ففيها توازن
بهذا الموضوع بينما السلكون بالي كان اكثر
الايداعات هي اذاعات غير مؤمنه 90% منها
واكثرتها ايداعات تحت الطلب فعشان هيك تم
السحب بهذا الطريقه اللي هي 40 بليون
دولار بنفس اليوم
الموضوع توسع هذا الهلع انا برايي راح
ممكن ينتقل يعني هلا احنا عم نحكي عن بعض
المدعين
مركزين براس المال المغامر الدين الخاص
بشكل عام خلال الفتره الماضيه من 2008 الى
2009 لحد اليوم ارتفع بشكل كثير كبير بسبب
انخفاض اسعار الفائده بسبب وجود بعض
الاستثمارات ولكن هاي اكثر الاستثمارات
الاستثمارات مرتبطه برجع بقول بالعقارات
مرتبطه بالعقارات اللي هي مرتبطه
بالعقارات المكتبيه او التجاريه وهذا لحد
هلا ما شفنا نتائجه يعني هاي في اقراض هون
يعتبر اقراض خطير ممكن يؤدي الى رفع سعر
الفائده الى الى مشاكل اكبر بهذا القطه
لهلا هذا ما انحكى عنه اللي هو كان سبب
الازمه بال 2008 2009 لو نتوقف قليلا عند
التداعيات العربيه بس لما تابعنا في
التقرير خمس
الاموال المودعه في كريدي سويس مثلا
خليجيه البنك الاهلي السعودي
جهاز قطر للاست هذان الطرفان تمت الاشاره
اليهما ما ابرز ما يمكن ان يتضرر سواء
البنك الاهلي او جهاز قطر هلا يعني هدول
اللي ظهروا كما كما قلت ممكن يظهر غيره
بالضبط ممكن في كتير
السياديه الخليجيه هي باوروبا بامريكا
وطبعا بحثا عن الارباح بحثا عن عن عن
تنويع الاقتصاد وغيرها ولكن عم بتكون
باماكن نوعا ما فيها مخاطره وهذه المخاطره
ممكن يكون لها تداعيات الفكره الاساسيه
اذا انت لاحظت بعد انهيار السيليكون
فاليوس
انخفضت الاسهم بكل
الدول الخليجيه تقريبا البورصه ايضا
البورصه والبنك الاهلي قيل لانه الاسهم
نزلت يعني شوف مباشره
الانعكاس هذا الانعكاس اذا ما عادوا توزيع
المحفظه الماليه
وعادوها انا برايي للاستثمارات الحقيقيه
مثل ما قال الدكتور الضيف انا براي طول ما
انه الاستثمارات عم تتحول الاستثمارات
تجاريه اسمها استثمارات لربحيه قصيره راح
يضل البنوك قطاع البنوك راح يضل يواجه
مخاطر
اقتصاديه ولكن بالنسبه للدول الخليج دكتور
مصطفى شاهين يقال دائما بان البنوك
المركزيه دائما في في الخليج تسرع في نجده
هذه البنوك والاطراف جهاز قطر او البنك
الاهلي او غيره حرص هذه الدول على نجده
البنوك سيساهم في التخفيف من اي انعكاسات
سلبيه
طبعا انت حضرتك بتتكلم على الدول الخليجيه
هي من افضل اقتصاديات في العالم من ناحيه
القوه الماليه من ناحيه المؤشرات لانك انت
اما تتكلم مثلا عن قطر او السعوديه او
الامارات او الكويت كل هذه الدول عندهم
احتياطيات ماليه ضخمه جدا من الدولار
تستطيع تنقذ اي بنك بيتعرض لازمه واحنا
اصلا يا استاذ محمد جزء من الصميم السيستم
او النظام المصرفي اي بنك حضرتك بتحط فيه
وديعه تلقائيا لازم يؤخذ نسبه من هذه
الوديعه وتوضع لدى البنك المركزي
الاجراءات دي بتبعت بعد سنه 29 في كل بنوك
العالم اي مواطن بيوضع وديعه لازم يؤخذ
منها جزء يروح للبنك المركزي ولا يتقاض
عليه البنك زي بنك الاهلي بنك قطر اي بنك
لا يتقاضى عليها اي عائد اصلا فالبنوك
المركزيه في الخليج قويه جدا لديها
احتياطيات ضخمه جدا من النقد الاجنبي
تستطيع تنقذ اي بنك من البنوك فليس فيها
اي مشكله على الاطلاق لكن انا مشكله
الحقيقه بالنسبه احنا في العالم العربي ان
انا ارغب ان انا اخرج من الاطار النمط
الفوائد البنكيه التقليديه لنظم اخرى اللي
هي النظم الاسلاميه مثلا نظام مثلا زي
نظام المشاركه او نظام زي نظام المرابحه
بس ده محتاج معايير اخرى ايضا عشان تنجح
محتاج ان يكون لدى المصارف في العالم
العربي القدره على الحكم على كفاءه
المواطن من الناحيه الماليه هل المواطن ده
عنده كفاءه ماليه كويسه هل يستطيع يسد
الدين اللي عليه هل يستطيع ان احنا لو
دخلنا في بيزنس البيزنس ده عندنا الضوابط
له كويسه اذا انت قدرت تخرج بهذا الاطار
انا اضمن لك
تنميه اعلى معدلات نمو افضل اضمن لك
معدلات تشغيل فرص عمل هتكون كويسه جدا
هيكون هناك مشاركات ضخمه جدا جدا واحنا
شفنا كده يعني عندك بنك الراجحي في
السعوديه قائم بدور عظيم جدا في قضيه
التنميه عندك بعض البنوك في اوروبا وفي
امريكا بتطبق الان نظام الصكوك الاسلاميه
ان انا اعطي عائد متغير واشارك في مشروعات
حقيقيه انما الازمه التي وقعت فيها البنوك
في امريكا ومن فتره طويله زي بنك سيليكون
فالي على سبيل المثال احنا بنتكلم عنه
للاسف الشديد كل استثماراته حاططها ان هو
اشترى سندات حكوميه بياخد فايده من
الحكومه او بيقرض فلوسه للحكومه والحكومه
بتدي له فايده الفايده ديت لما بمجرد
الحكومه رفعت الفائده انهارت قيمه
السدادات الحكوميه يعني مفيش استثمار جديد
يخلق فرص جديده حتى هو كان بيعطي اقراض
للشركات التكنولوجيه هذه القروض اللي
بيعطيها للشركات هي عباره عن اقراض الشركه
فلست الشركه ضاعت الشركه وضعها الشركه
مديونه بهذا الدين طبعا
[موسيقى]
مطروح عليها الان اعاده الهيكله
وربما بالنسبه لكريدي سويس مثلا
سيضطر من هنا الى 2025 الى تسريح تقريبا
9000 عامل وموظف هم تقريبا 17% من القوه
العامله هل المرحله المقبله بسبب هذه
الازمه ستكون مرحله اعاده هيكله لمعظم
البنوك في اوروبا
في الواقع اعتقد ان هناك مشكله اساسيه
فيما يتعلق السويس هو انه
مصرف كبير جدا متعدد الاوجه في القاع
لدينا في قاعدات لدينا مصرف تجزئه هنا في
سويسرا ثم لدينا اداره اصول واداره وثروات
ومصرف استثماري وبالتالي ما نراه هو ان
الجزء المصرفي للاستثمارات في سويس كما هو
حال الكثير مصاريف البنوك الاستثماريه هو
انها عملها جزء هذا جزء من عمل المصرف
خطير جدا ويبتسم بالمخاطر واعتقد ان هذا
يندمج مع
اوجئه الله جزء من عمل المصرف لانه هناك
دائما خطر انه اذا ما تعرضوا لخسائر كبيره
كما يحصل بين حين واخر في هذا النوع من
الاعمال فان التاثيرات ذلك تكون سلبيه على
قوه
متانه الشروق الظروف الماليه للمصرف
وبالتالي يبدو لي انه لابد ان نكون دقيقين
جدا فيما يتعلق بالتعامل مثل هذا النوع من
النشاط التجاري ولا بد ان نكون دقيقين
وحديثا في الصناعه المصرفيه لكي نعرف الى
اي مدى يمكن
دمج هذا النوع من الناشطات مع نشاطات
المصرفيه الاخرى
كما تعلمون لديها
زائد سويسرا لديها
صناعه اداره الثروات كبيره جدا وبالتالي
فانما حصل مع كرد سويس مؤسف ومحبط لانه
ذلك الى حد ما سيدفع بالعملاء بالتفكير
بان المصارف المصارف السويسيه خطره وهذا
ليس مفيدا لسويسرا كونها مركزا ماليا في
العالم
عندما تحدد تتحدث كريستيارد رئيسه البنك
المركزي الاوروبي عن ان هذه الازمه ستطرح
مخاطر جديده تهدد الاقتصاد
اوروبيه ماذا يمكن ان تكون هذه المخاطر
انها ربما تشعر بالقلق ازاء شيئين اولهما
او وحده مصادر قلق الرئيسيه في اوروبا هو
ان الحكومات
لديها ديون كبيره في جنوب اوروبا مثل
اسبانيا وايطاليا بشكل خاص
واليونان وقبرص والبرتغال وما الى ذلك
هناك خطر كما يرى كثير من المتابعين ان ان
معدلات الانسان سعر الفائده ترتفع في
اوروبا فان المستثمرين الذي كان يشترونها
اسهم هذه الحكومات عندما كانت اسعارها
منخفضه الان سيقولون ان المعدلات الفائده
ستفعت وبالتالي نود اعاده
توطين
ملفاتنا وتقرير تعاملنا مع الحكومات
ولنحمل سندات من الحكومات اخرى مخاصه
المانيا او ربما الهولاندو وما الى ذلك
وهذا قد يؤدي الى تو
القلق والخوف والفرق بين ايطاليا والمانيا
وهذا سيزيد تعقيد اداره السياسات النقديه
ان ان السوق المحليه تؤثر على تسعير تسعير
المنتجات الماليه بشكل كبير والخطر الاخر
حسب رايي واذا ارتفعت اسعار الفائده فانه
سيكون هناك المزيد من المقترضين وخاصه في
سوق العقارات المنازل وتسيدون صعب جدا ان
يخدم ان يسددوا فوائد ديونهم على القروض
التي اخذوها وهذا قد يؤدي الى مشاكل قاسيه
وشديده جدا في بعض
المناطق المنعزله في اوروبا ولكن بالنسبه
لبعض الدول الدكتور جلال القناص الدول
العربيه تعاني الان من ازمات اقتصاديه
متعدده لبنان تونس مصر
هل يمكن ان تنعكس عليهم هذه الازمه بشكل
او باخر طبعا يعني هلا كما تحدثنا اذا
اثرت على الاقتصاد العالمي وتحولنا الى
ركود اقتصادي عالمي بسبب مثل ما حكينا سب
رئيسي بسبب سياسات البنوك المركزيه عدم
الرقابه الماليه وكل هالمشاكل اذا ما
قدرنا استعاده الثقه طبعا اكثر الدول
العربيه سوف تعاني سوف تتحول انه هاي
الدول كمان هي بحاجه للمساعده اذا الدول
المساء اذا دول الخليجيه ليس لديها القدره
على مساعده هذه الدول اللي هي الاساسيه
هذا له تاثير كبير راح ياثر على موضوع
الدولار لانه اكثر هاي الدول اللي عم
تعاني من شح الدولار وعم تعاني من مشاكل
اقتصاديه يجمع يعني مو بس على على
المستويات المختلفه فالاغلب طبعا راح تكون
عملتها مرتبطه بالدولار مثل دول الخليج
معظمها تقريبا كلها
هذا الارتباط سيخدمها هذه نوعا ما نعم
لانه البنك المركزي عم بشتغل عم بيعمل ما
يسمى مقرض الملاذ الاخير فدائما عم بتدخل
مثل ما شفت يعني انا بعتبرها حلول تجميليه
ولكن عم بيتدخل يعني بموضوع السيليكون
فالي مباشره تدخل عمل تامين على على كل
الودائع اللي موجوده واعاد اعاد شرائها
نفس الشيء
السويسري تدخل بشكل مباشر فهنا عم بيحتوها
بهالطريقه انا برايي لازم يكون في اساسيات
بالعمل بالذات موضوع الرقابه الماليه
والاستقرار المالي والعمل على عدم دفع
الاقتصاد نوع نحو الركود الاقتصادي
بالنسبه لدول الخليج انا برايي يعني
ارتباط بترو دولار مثل ما بنسميه
نوعا ما عم بيخدمها بسبب يعني الوضع
الحالي في ارتفاع يعني الاسعار نوعا ما
جيده ولكن على المدى الطويل يجب ان يفكروا
بتنويع هذه المحفظه الماليه حتى يصير
الانعكاسات بالنسبه للد اقل بالنسبه
للدول التي اشرت اليها مصر او لبنان او
تونس هناك راي لجلال بيومي لمين العام
للاتحاد المستثمرين العرب قال راي طريف
قال احيانا يكون صغر الحجم حجم البلد
العربي يقصد هنا ميزه عند المصائب
الاقتصاديه الكبرى يعني عندما يكون لديك
اقتصاد ليس لديك اقتصاد كبير ومرتبط
ارتباط عضوي بالاقتصاد العالمي فعلى الاقل
الضربه تكون ربما اخف نريد ان نقوم بجوله
في نهايه هذه الحلقه نبدا بالدكتور مصطفى
شاهين ثم ستيفن وننتهي مع الدكتور جلال
القناص
ما توقعاتك في النهايه في ضوء ما تحدثنا
فيه مسيناريوهات المرجحه لتطور هذه الازمه
في الفتره القليله المقبله على الاقل
هو اولا كما بدا لنا اللي فيه تخوفات من
المذيعين فالناس بدات تسحب فلوسها من
البنوك وبدات تشتري بها دهب رفع اسعار
الذهب ويرفع اسعار الذهب في المنطقه
العربيه بالكامل ارتفاع اسعار الذهب للاسف
سيجر من وراه ايضا زياده في الطلب على
الدولار في بعض الدول اللي بتعاني من ازمه
زي ما حضرتك تفضلت زي مصر السودان تونس
الاردن وضعها افضل كثيرا ايضا لبنان هذه
الدول ستواجه ايضا للاسف الشديد بارتفاعات
في اسعار الدولار وارتفاع في اسعار الذهب
هيخفض القيمه الوطنيه للعملات الوطنيه
سيؤدي الى ارتفاع في الاسعار على المستوى
العالمي على مستوى امريكا واوروبا تحديدا
هناك اجراءات تشدديه ستاخذها البنوك
المركزيه والمصارف في الفيدره في امريكا
من اجل الحد من هذه الازمات ولكن للاسف
الشديد ايضا
هنالك هيكون في تجديد على الاقراض للشركات
وده هيؤدي الى مزيد من البطاله بل ربما
نجد ان احنا ندخل في مرحله من مراحل
الركود داخل اوروبا وامريكا خاصه مع
ارتفاعات معدلات التضخم التي بلغت قرابه
سبعه واحد من عشره في الميه في امريكا
اوروبا وامريكا الان احنا في طريقه تعافي
الان حقيقه من من اجراءات الكورونا ربما
تستغرق فتره لكن هنالك تحسن اراه في نهايه
النفق لنرى ما يقول سيد ستيفان
بعد ان يشرب الماء طبعا
اذا انا اعتقد
ان الاحتمال الاكبر في المستقبل هو ان
الازمه
تنخفض
والمستثمرون سيشعرون بثقه والمقرضون اذ لن
تحصل لها اي افلاسات والامور ستستقر ولكن
هناك خط يبقى هناك خطرا وهو وهو خطر مادي
ليس ليس صفر ليس قريب من الصفر يبقى خطر
ان مصارف المركزيه قد تسترفع اسعار
الفائده اكثر وبالتالي سنجد المزيد من
فصول التوترات الماليه كما شاهدنا في
الولايات المتحده قبل اسبوعين وان الازمه
ستعود مره اخرى وبشكل مفاجئ جدا وبشكل غير
متوقع اطلاقا وهذا هو مصدر قلق ومخاوف هل
لديك اي توقع زمني
مدى استمرار مثل هذه الازمه
اعتقد على الارشح حسب رايي
الشهر او شهرين القادمين سيكونان حساسان
ومهمان
نعم نعم اعتقي اذا من ناحيه المبدئيه
عندما تزيد المصرف المركزيه معدلات سعر
الفائده لن تحصل المشكله فورا لكن بمرور
الوقت بعض المؤسسات الماليه تضع نفسها في
الاسواق الماليه بطريقه بحيث انها تضر
تتضرر اذا ما ارتفت اسعار الفائده وبمرور
الزمن يمرون
بمتاعب وصعوبات كثيره بحيث يقعلون الافلاس
وما الى ذلك وبالتالي علينا ننتظر قليلا
لابد مرور بعض الوقت ولكن اعتقد بعض
الاشهر الشهر
القادمين سيكون لنا خطرين او حساسين بشكل
خاص
دكتور جلال القناص بالنسبه اليك كيف ترى
السيناريو الفتره المقبله انا اعتقد طالما
ان البنوك المركزيه وبالذات البنك المركزي
الامريكي
سيتوجه بزياده سعر الفائده
ستستمر البنوك بهاي المشاكل كل المشاكل هي
متعلقه بهاي السندات الموجوده عم تنخفض
قيمتها كل ما ارتفعت سعر الفائده فهذا ما
عم بيروح يعني اذا ما البنك المركزي غير
هاي السياسه وما وجه الاقتصاد نحو الركود
الاقتصادي العالمي اللي ممكن يؤثر على
المنطقه على امريكا وعلى اوروبا وعلى
الدول العربيه وبالذات متل ما قلت الدول
اللي تعاني من وضع جدا سيء بالتضخم
وبالركود وغيرها انا برايي سوف تستمر
وممكن انا براي غير متفاجئ لانه عم بيقول
الزميل او انه ممكن يصير شيء مفاجئ انا
برايي غير مفاجئ لانه نعرف انه في مشاكل
بالبنوك في مشاكل الميزانياتها والبنوك
المركزيه تعرف هذا ولكن ما زالت تحاول
تعالج الامور بالحلول التجميليه ولا
تعالجها من خلال الاشياء الاساسيه مثل
الرقابه الماليه هل معنى ذلك انما قاله
السيد جيرلاخ ربما متفائل قليلا انه بضعه
اشهر
وتستقر الامور
متفائل جدا
اعتقد متفائل جدا لانه
المسببات لم تذهب اكثر البنوك البنوك
الاوروبيه والامريكيه تحمل السندات
الحكومه
25% الوسطي 25% من سندات الحكومه موجوده
هذا لم ندخل بموضوع القروض العقاريه موضوع
قروض القروض الشركات التجاريه يعني
التجاره العقاريه هذا السماء دخلنا على
هذا الخط مازلنا نتحدث عن السندات
الحكوميه عن بعض الايداعات اذا وصلت لحد
مثل ما حدث بال20289 للديون الخاصه اللي
هي مرتبطه بالعقارات انا برايي رح تتوجه
الامور لوضع اسوء اذا طلبنا منك ان تقدم
لنا مقارنه بين ازمه 2008
وبدايه هذه الازمه على الاقل هل من مقارنه
هلا ببعض الخصائص تعتبر مختلفه يعني
السبب الرئيسي ارتفاع اسعار المنازل
ادى لوجود منتجات ماليه حديثه صار فيها
نوع من الطلب العالي رفعه الارباح وصلت
لمرحله لما لما صار في انخفاض باسعار
المنازل صار الازمه
الوضع الحالي نوعا ما مختلف لانه صار بعض
الرقابه الماليه ولكن برجع بقول مسببات
الوضع عمل البنوك وطريقه عمل البنوك لم
تتغير في خطوره مثل ما قال الدكتور شاهين
عم نتحول اكتر القروض اللي هي تبع الربح
السريع ما عم نكون على قروض انتاجيه لازم
يكون عمل البنوك اللي هو البنك المركزي
لازم يركز عليه اللي هو الاقراض على
الاقراض الانتاجي وهذا ما نحتاجه الاقتصاد
الحقيقي اين هو الاقتصاد الحقيقي من هذه
من هذه العمليه التنموي بالضبط الاقتصاد
الحقيقي التنموي شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور جلال
القناص شكرا لحضورك معنا هنا في الاستوديو
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا الدكتور مصطفى شاهين مره
اخرى كل عام وانت بخير انت والدكتور ج لال
وشكرا ايضا دكتور السيد سليمان
شكرا لحضوركم جميعا بهذا المشاهدين الكرام
نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه
الله ورمضان كريم مره اخرى
[موسيقى]